hi my name is Jeff um John and my title
of topic is tough problem solving in
geometry so I'm gonna just show some
problem in geometry that is that I
silicate from so motor your friend
community I'm gonna go over how to solve
it using Mathematica I mean old friend
language geometry features so what I
want to do is actually type problem so
what kind of problem
I'm due to some time limit I'm not gonna
do like a one color conjecture now I'm
kind of select some problems over the
roof and communities and then I kind of
lagged by the popularity and group them
in southern area like construction
relations major visualization so if you
see the kitchen some question I simple
but it had some popularity so that means
in in my point of view caption we didn't
like let me see the first one how do I
draw triangle given the lengths of the
side very basic geometry question and
like before like button can to cyber
this probably have to do some linear
education siding because we don't have
functionality so let's just check it so
for now from button 10 I believe we have
new traffic limited called childhood so
anyone know about these primitive order
it probably some of them interested in
graphic know about this but not just
triangle we also have family of trying
like SSS triangle is something some
weird name II but s means side so this
triangle construct actually impeded the
side length ABC so exactly what this
question about so if you give
length of side three Popeye for ejector
then little value will be the triangle
so this one now it's pointed and good
thing about
function not function the culture
southern cases you cannot construct
triangle with any anonymous side filling
up this one it tells you why you can
appeal the triangle with the side legs
like a temp should we let them some
upsides rainfall and other family we
have a sa angle-side-angle
and also we have angering the side side
angle side so now this question you know
why and there are some some many answers
related to linear Serbs are reduced now
you can just do this one comment and
this is kind of similar problem how to
inscribe a circle in a given triangle we
have two new namu if from bottom ten we
have some primitive released its appear
becomes pure basically input this point
this one can be extended to 3d and puddi
that's why a 3d so that's why we call it
appear but if you give like slip point
actually giving soccer so for example I
just make manipulator
training the point into a point and then
you see you have Sapir inside keep
changing and this is another function
comparison function like how it's giving
the soccer outside of given three-point
and just another page question how to
construct simple polygons in a given
point simple polygon means simply say
the polygon without that intersect so
when you have just three point like
triangle you never want to have some
type intersect the triangle all polygons
like this one but this is one of the
example that which is much improved so
you see the 13 tough in the middle right
so the cursor is in such a case how can
we guarantee the little polygon is
simple without this circle intersection
so one of the easiest way you just plug
in the point into a comebacks or mesh
this will create
[ __ ] mesh this is not polygon right now
but you can extract a polygon so now
this is a simple polygon without a
selfie it's affecting and the given for
point is this and what to do but in some
cases if you have so many polygons like
this if you build comebacks or mesh you
see some point to feel inside of this
mesh because this is convex
we don't allow this kind of concave I'd
say down or whatever in this case if you
just really want to portfolio on the
passing through all these points given
point which is not combat you can use
finally shoot it for now if the question
is turned out to be I'll starve like a
Chinese postman problem so what is
function dog is fine the path depth
touching every point we self
intersecting so this is order of the
given point and if we use this order you
see now you have polygons which satisfy
our requirement and miserable Malaysia
now so what does it mean by relation so
relation between the object so for
example like how to check it for to the
point is in polygon so if you just
imagine it's very easy right you draw a
polygon see where the point is it is
inside
Pena's inside it is outside outside but
but I mean if you want to program those
things it's not easy like a pack pair
you have to push the prefect winding
numbers and do some shim
make like a switch of linear equation
and check this inside town off it's not
easy so for like a new version 10 and 11
we kind of have introduced some some
relation function between legends so
like Legendary's legend member which is
kind of main function
this joint within this pan and I will
show you how we want to use this
function to type that simple problem so
we share studies Emperor so I just proud
country data so this is polygons of
Australia and I want to check some point
if I do this polygon or not so it's just
a function ledger member what it does is
if you the first argument will be the
polygon or any radium and then this two
point or one point and it giving tour
for sweet like how this one is mad in
this one is in for central or some other
way if you use this polygon over and
over again to check the membership you
can just create major member function
and this function can use repeatedly
this point so quite fast in this case so
here's the some dynamic pain bouquet to
pain example so like LED means inside
very quite fast so you can dynamically
free some point it inside or outside and
same question now is 3d point but it
doesn't make that much difference it's a
ledger member it doesn't matter that you
mentioned it just works so for example
at this year so we have the graphics
looks like a bore and then the question
is we want to verify this set of point
is some point is inside some points
outside we just want to verify that so
first things you T's create a graphic
and then chocolate a member but in this
case you see there is nothing inside
what happen is this one actually looks
like forest here so it doesn't have a
inside
so if empty objects so that means there
is no tamil inside and outside if only
on the pockets or not so the easiest way
to check
that if you see if you solid means
building or not you see it spores so to
solve this problem we first need to make
some solid object so shared I just get a
coordinate of this Thomas appear and use
the boundary as a boundary mesh region
so now we got the solid object so we can
now verify point inside so it's just
inside outside and you see this is point
inside and here's the outside and
combining you can see the visual member
correctly specify outside and inside and
this another basic geometric question so
how to determine the center and radius
of circle given some point in 3d so we
have given six point and we want to see
if this six point actually construct the
soccer in 3d space and again so what I'm
going to do is it's just using some
simple geometric properties so my plan
is I construct two region one is
infinite playing the containing three
point three point you have to play in
life and then Sock'em spear which is
conserved by three point but given three
point anything and the one that is not
in the plane so you got the circum spear
and if you see the intersection because
your inspection pit is superior in plane
depth entry you will get soccer in the
freedom ensures I just pluck it given
point it looks like it is a case and to
verify it
I do later member but here's
appraisingly we got some false case this
is due to some numerical you know better
so given point was numeric if you plug
in the exact number this will be true
but this is very thin line it had to be
honest
the numeric because of the digit and
octave tracery two things it's not easy
but in this case if you see that these
pants with the soccer we create and the
point you see it's almost zero so in
this case if you chop you see this point
indeed a nice it's almost cultural
soccer importing the center you just
using the edge of centroid with totally
fine and you know radius will be just
distance between the center we find at
any point so this is radius and to
verify this is actually it's a soccer we
want I just using formula for parametric
circle in 3d and see this factor we want
so this is just no time to placate in
this twinkling line so there are new to
define pointing in line you can use only
you to point but you can choose any
point but it looks different and we want
to delete the which one with I mean in
July which on the same in the night like
a chair with using for infinite light
but if you practice unity to so there
are two plication but if you just using
delete duplicate function you cannot
verify which one is same because it
deviates duplicate it just see the input
from all perform in this case but if you
use they don't equal as the chapter then
now you quickly need the same region so
legend equally store actually see the
geometry and check if it's same page or
not and now it's a major so it's for
calculating volume or some culture is
the first one color calculate volume of
comebacks or you know it's just
Vijay weekly called combat swimmers we
can do ledger major which is kind of
general function but also we can just do
volume not nothing's pressure the COO
simple boy they don't measure it major
major it report it checked out
dimensional region and using that as the
deciding factor maybe area or volume but
if you just using volume it always find
volume body mean is for area if you do
this
anything pin it because this is solid
object so that kind of differed and
here's another similar problem but now
we want to find volume of Provost which
is the delight of math but this from
example data if you do volume it get
your why resist or similar user
previously it's not only the way don't
you
so I do try to do same thing what I did
but you cannot control boundary mesh
region that means there are some some
detective so let's see what's going on
here using the most famous detective
unction if you see it you do soon you
see there are opening overlapping faces
that this one is thirty fact that
prevent to control boundary mesh region
currently we don't have a pair of
function like a deeper mesh but this one
we don't support fixing operating faces
so I gonna do a little bit more work to
do it so I'm gonna just be moved the
overlapping faces from original mesh and
then construct mesh you see the little
hole before is created by removing that
operating basis and then I'll only pure
mesh now it's problem is just filling
the hole I created and the primers can
take care of it so let me just show you
so you see you don't see it or any more
and then now you can construct
the boundary mesh region which is solid
object and then you can compute volume
so using the ultra hyper let's check
what is actual volume of robot so it's
the 1374 my cube and this one is
actually
geometers so let me combat the geometry
then see if i shimla we cannot see - oh
yeah that's true yeah now
so now the computing the Gaussian
curvature on discrete sockets so the
formula I want to use is this one is you
live from cosmonium
so what this theorem says the 2pi - so
mobile anger at each point and some of
area each point abide by three so this
is the simple formula and find so we
have mesh I just chose one ellipsoid
which is easy and easy to verify the car
better computation is correct so I just
wanna just operate that the formula that
I show you so first thing for this a
each point we need to you know find out
the neighborhood polygon
this is undocumented but you can use on
the mesh you can find the connectivity
matrix 0 comma 2 means point and the
polygon and what it does is so clean up
like here you see point index 1 you have
1 2 3 4 5 6 polygons
this is polygon index so this is how it
looks right this is point 1 and then you
have 6 polygons around it using this
polygon this is function that I just
defined to find anger so here this
polygon angle will be angle between
these two patches here and just show you
one case this is anger at Point P of
each triangle you see here and for area
you do the same thing but now instead of
computing anger we use the area which
you can also find using property value
so this one return this to the area of
each polygon in order so earlier will be
this so I just going to combine this two
function to define
total the calcium copper so here this
part connected to matrix and this is
plat for solving the area and here's
something anger and then this is exactly
what
you see you just played it on the
formula for the culture and culture and
if I do this so this is the setup
Gaussian curvature for each point
curvature and if I use this function
that I define so this is the graphic or
Gaussian curvature on this cylinder you
see here which is a little bit higher
because of the the step round and here's
some more example that I use that
coverage function so this website in
this case the locator on which is
defined by implication and then I define
curvature with using this original
education and formula so this is kind of
the earth curvature and this is the one
that s estimated by the functionality
pine so it's pretty good estimation and
here this is mesh on exam data and this
is capture and here's another you will
even improve curvature effect on the
body and this is fine our collection
visualization is just feed your
digestion the first one is about
animating a balloon Mary I of them what
question was is like a you have foreign
lead I follow my diagram of met point
this landing point and can you animate
some transformation from point to this
Prannoy diagram so what I told you here
so I just keep cells from this mesh
region so it's like our here sir and
this one is corresponding point in the
air and then I apply some function say
for my imperfection so later on
intersection between some soccer which
really changing is site over time and
then the sir I extract here so let me
just show you
but from reading so this is original
point with some little sucker and then
if you're moving it keeps evolving and
actually if you come to online so kind
of transformation animation and next one
the last one is like a partition appear
so this is the result what you want so
what was question is right now we have
given within videos I mean just poor and
we have point and some faith that
dividing the spear orb or so and then
how can it partition those poor
respectable section I mean for example I
cut this one is just one face so that
face I just define chronic or the
passing through each face so this you
see here is the one efficient and other
face also depend on partition so there's
many way but like I said just intuition
what how can you get this partition we
can just intersect between this conical
region found and then board then we got
a section so that's what actually I did
so I just plug in this space even and
create called chronic or defined by
those faces and then just very
intersection and I wanna get a partition
here like you see and then mapping color
to each side and combining dessert and
you better additional or so there's more
more questions but you know I only have
like 20 minutes so this is where I have
for now and then you know and you can
see some question is so trivial but it
trivial but had to you know actually
making function in like Apple isn't like
other that
well polygons membership checking to see
but those questions we keep checking
here listen the user who kissed and then
keep making some new function they make
to strap eg so that's kind of thing what
we are doing and for the geometry you
know the new framework allowed to come
into table style bottom problem like
this one this one is you know what I did
is just imagination like an intersection
oh very straightforward but it works so
those kind of things is one of the
things we want in I mean there will be
more things you can do this way you know
commit was an openness medica
so this endo talk and here's if anybody
that doesn't check our geometry
exhibition in the downstairs is pretty
cool is unity integration with
Mathematica and we only have it will
close at 4:00 so you have one and half
hours to check it if you don't so yeah
[Applause]
[Music]